la bandera ucraniana es izada sobre la
alcaldía decisión tras meses de
ocupación pero ahora que los rusos se
han ido llega el momento de dejar las
cosas claras poco después de la
liberación de la ciudad los residentes
se reunieron aquí y señalaron a los que
aceptaron la ayuda rusa como raciones de
comida
vendiste ucrania por un poco de comida
y tú que has estado comiendo acaso eres
visión
comíamos nuestra propia comida
comer inicio un bajo la ocupación era
casi una tarea imposible ya que la
ciudad se quedó sin agua gas y
electricidad
nos quedamos en los sótanos sin agua ni
comida rusia ofrecía ayuda humanitaria y
al principio me negué a aceptarla pero
para ser sincera no quería aceptar nada
de rusia pero no teníamos nada que comer
teníamos que sobrevivir los lugareños
también rechazaron al alcalde del pueblo
que huyó cuando llegaron los rusos
el alcalde nos traicionó nos abandonó
sin agua sin electricidad
pero eso también es motivo de debate
pero eso no es cierto
hay mucha otra gente que se fue y cuando
los rusos vinieron con ayuda humanitaria
todos estaban allí para tomarla
antes de la guerra cuarenta y seis mil
personas vivían en misión hoy sólo
quedan unos pocos miles la rápida
retirada de las fuerzas rusas ha dejado
al descubierto las brutalidades de más
de seis meses de ocupación